how do you employee see you  yeah well a couple things um  because i wanna i wanna answer your  question very specifically about us but  then i wanna make a broader point about  how i think it relates to your you know  you and and other people out there and  people watching us right now  so  i think it just shows again my main  point about how low the bar is  because  we assume  and  frankly pretty much correctly so  that everybody out there that has  ownership and power and those sorts of  things  is going to flip  and basically trade the things that  matter in life  which are  relationships  care  love trust integrity  for the things that don't matter in life  uh or don't matter as much once you have  enough